wird dies hat schon vor langer zeit sein
büro auf die straße verlegt der
bundestagskandidat der linken weiß
anders wird er hier kaum stimmen
gewinnen
warum gehen die menschen eigentlich
nicht mehr wählen haben wie ihr
vertrauen in die politik verloren
duisburg hochfeld im westen deutschlands
ist der wahlkreis mit dem meisten
nichtwähler nur noch jeder fünfte papier
zuletzt bei der kommunalwahl seine
stimme ab vor über 30 jahren ging es den
menschen in der stadtregion noch gut
doch von den rund 20.000 einwohnern
verloren viele ihre arbeit heute leben
zwei drittel von staatlicher hilfe
mercedes hat die geschichte des
niedergangs hautnah miterlebt er ist in
hochfeld aufgewachsen wir hatten ja
jugendzentrum die zugemacht haben
stadtbad dazu gemacht die freizeitparks
sind nicht mehr so attraktiv wie sie mal
früher waren das heißt man hat nicht
mehr in diesen bereichen investiert und
letztendlich ist es halt die politik die
falsche politik die jetzt dazu geführt
hat dass die menschen
das vertrauen in die politik so gesehen
verloren haben und deshalb auch nicht
mehr zur wahl gehen
400 haushalte ungefähr 2.000 menschen
kommen hier jede woche zur tafel einem
verein der gespendete lebensmittel
verteilt arbeitslose einwanderer armuts
rentner bekommen hier vieles was sie
sich so nie leisten könnten
die mitarbeiter verstehen gut warum ihr
kaum einer wählen geht
arme leute haben andere sorgen als zu
wählen und ich glaube dass sich die
politik und die menschen immer weiter
voneinander entfernen
jemand der sich heute darum sorgen
machen muss wurden seinen coach hier in
seinem putsch eingefüllt bekommt der wm
interessiert nicht mehr ob die spd oder
die cdu oder wer auch immer regiert den
man auch hier anspricht die enttäuschung
über die parteien ist groß aber wie sie
seien auch nur selten thema der großen
politik
[Musik]
die entscheiden selber wollen
hinzu kommt in duisburg hochfeld leben
fast 70 prozent einwanderer selbst er
von ihnen die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft hat gezählten zur
wahl es ist für mich auch sehr sehr
schwierig diese menschen für politik zu
gewinnen und auch dazu zu bewegen dass
sie auch halt auch zu gehen und dann
halte ihre stimme abgeben weil sie
überhaupt kein vertrauen in das
politische system war
mercedes will nicht dass nur die
gebildeten und reichen wählen gehen
deshalb wird er in seinem viertel noch
viel unterwegs sein müssen um die
menschen hier wieder für die demokratie
zu gewinnen